Bill Beckham Jr was forced to get off an  American Airlines flight the flight crew  said he appeared to be in and out of  Consciousness and they said they were  concerned for his safety and feared that  his condition would worsen throughout  the flight so they called the police and  fire rescue obj's lawyer released a  statement saying that Odell was fine and  that he just fell asleep with a blanket  over his head which is his normal  practice for long flights when he woke  up the plane was back at the gate and  Odell was told that he needed to leave  the aircraft immediately the other  passengers on the plane were obviously  pissed since their plane was delayed two  hours because of this fiasco